you know here's the thing um
in july it was two years since i've had
a drink
because uh two years because
um as we said i don't think i'm gonna
have grandkids for many many years
and i when they come i'll probably be
about 75
and so i need my brain like i don't want
to be that drooling grandmother
in the corner you know that you have to
go kiss and then run away from i want to
be an
active level you know so so i haven't
been drinking to preserve my brain
right yeah however it doesn't seem to
have helped that much because
um the other night
i get a text from my youngest son and he
says
well happy birthday to me i guess
and i realized my mother did this once
and not only was it was it his birthday
it was his 21st
birthday oh no
i'm at the top of the stairs this was
like before the pandemic so he was still
at school
i yelled down i held down the stairs
dave
we forgot dan's birthday dave's like oh
my god
so i at its 24th birthday so i felt
so so bad that i started texting every
celebrity friend that i had and i
gave them dan's phone number
and i um said please will you text my
son dennis his 21st birthday i forgot
please just text him wish him happy
birthday tell him tell him i'm a
terrible parent
and he dan was very impressed first of
all
his roommates at college were very
impressed that ashley tisdale was
texting him
so oh my gosh she's so nice it's so nice
and she was having a conversation with
her she told me later her husband said
who are you texting and she said a bunch
of college boys
but the best one was um ray romano
sent me a video or sent dan a video and
then he said it to me and it's
really funny what he said i think you
have it
hey dan i know it's a little noisy
uh i'd understand it's your 21st
birthday according to my calendar
i guess your your parents don't have the
same calendar that i do
but i keep track of things so happy 21st
birthday
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going